oh man guys it's finally happening the
end times are here I can't wait to tell
you all about my lowdown and my bug-out
bag I'll show you the basics to prep and
all that and I'm excited as you should
be excited we finally get to loot
through all of our neighbors belongings
now I'm not gonna be going into any of
the basic stuff you know all the basics
loves math duct tape for windows that's
sort of dumb stuff what I want to get
into is the fun stuff first things first
think about your personal lowdown I may
be different for you guys I'm an
all-male a guy
mostly knives a couple of different
blunt weapons just in case the zombies
start so this is a kit ray dark elf
knife waiting for this yeah give me that
toilet paper you could do the blender
all right I know what you're thinking
really you're the melee guy and you're
gonna tell me about a katana but they
truly are the perfect weapon this is the
bayonet my grandpappy used to killing
dozen Nazis now see oh boy I am you got
yourself a little Morning Star here and
hopefully we start getting like legit
zombies out of this right like hopefully
it's not just a bunch of coughing old
people looking for suplies like that's
so boring look it may be loud but a
chainsaw
is though that we gasoline search on and
out and maybe a problem but that's gonna
take good months at least you know when
you're considering it your bug out bag
another thing to think about is leaving
empty space give yourself ample room for
lose something you really need to think
about having in your bug out bag is an
emergency blanket they take up like no
space you're ready in case it starts
raining on you and who knows you know
maybe maybe the disease has gone
airborne and you just need to keep it
off of you maybe it helps keep the
government out of your odd yep maybe
think about having a little one of these
all like camping for keeps pretty eyes
they're uh they're really easy to clean
um they're really useful pick yourself
up a long-distance radio we got
ourselves the TRC 211 here this guy can
reach the moon something a lot of people
don't think about when it comes to your
bug out bag is security
now some people are gonna recommend
using locks but I think using a bag
snake is your best bet now this is a
snake you put in your bag and that's
just gonna that's gonna stop anyone
who's trying to try to rob from you
because you know people freak out when
they see snakes so the next thing to
think about are alternative food sources
you've got to start thinking outside the
box with what's gonna go in your Tumtum
so one thing a lot of people don't
realize is that there's about thirty
calories in every tube of toothpaste
which that'll get you through a part of
the day and
there are certain types of cardboard
that are edible you can get it so yeah
well you think about it there's a lot of
food you to lie in around the house okay
yeah don't look at like I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna get all the toilet paper just
remember guys burn with the apocalypse
hey I'm gonna go down to drink your
juice and see if I can yeah
what's up yellow we are living in crazy
times a lot of you all are trapped in
your house right now you guys might be
getting a little lethargic you might be
a little depressed even I know the
feeling honestly the best way for me to
deal with that kind of stuff is fitness
and working out so that's what we're
here to do today pretty little workout
in we're gonna do a little stretch with
a little warmup
we'll get the workout and then we'll do
a cool-down as well so that you guys
will not go insane in these crazy times
so the most important thing we gotta
start with a warm-up can't get a workout
going if your bones and your muscles are
all Colding me snapping things to be
going to a hospital and you do not want
to be in the hospital right now however
you can warm up warm up whether it's
jumping jacks like a dance routine
invisible jump rope okay you just got to
get that blood pumping okay that's great
get the heart rate up you know feeling
right now now it's time to get into the
workout let's do it okay it's a very
simple workout very very effective
basically we have 15 push-ups 15
crunches and 15 squats so that's one set
you're gonna do three sets told now
depending on your skill level you can
change that number you can do 10
push-ups you can go up to 30 push-ups
whatever you guys need to do that's
totally fine
also if you want to take it to the next
level another thing you can do is
exchange out the workout so you can take
your pushup from a normal push-up to a
more difficult pushup like a triangle
push-up you do a tricep push-up you do a
wide arm and push-up clap push-ups
whatever you guys need to do same goes
for the crunches too right you can do
normal crunches you can do sit-ups
butterfly kicks leg lifts basically
whatever you guys need to do to adjust
it to your skill level that's the whole
point as long as you're getting a
workout doesn't matter what it looks
like as long as your
and move in two final quick tips for you
guys after your workout there's a number
of things you can do to cool down my
favorite things to do lay down on the
ground and either grab a yoga block or a
stack of books about that thick and put
it basically right above your butt and
just lay down on this thing and just
feel you'll feel it just open up your
lower back relax we'll breathe and it's
basically the best thing in the whole
world
last quick tip for you guys when you
wake up in the morning or halfway
through the day and you need a little
stretch all you're gonna do is breathe
in get those hands up go to the left go
to the right back to Center exhale
forward fold and this is basically the
best thing ever
this will get all of the weight off of
your lower back
you know bend your knees as much as you
need to you don't want to hurt yourself
cross your arms little dangle whatever
one you can rock your head yes you can
rock your head no
you can swim side side a little bit and
basically just hang out here for a
little just make sure when you come up
come up one vertebra at a time slowly
let your head be the last thing to come
up do everything to breath make sure you
breathe large in all this so I issue a
challenge to you guys I challenge you
all to film your workout whether it's
just a segment of your workout whole
thing do a time-lapse whatever send it
to the corridor crew Instagram gives a
little hashtag quarantine crew and we'll
take a look at all those workouts so
wear this together as long as this
quarantine lasts we just need to stay
healthy and active it's raining outside
I've been cooped up in here all week
editing and I just want to go outside
I even snag the one-wheel from the
studio just to get me through this
quarantine you know I think there's a
good opportunity to talk about anxiety
which I'm sure we're all feeling right
now
with everything that's going on and I'm
sure it's something that a lot of you
have been going through since long
before coronavirus myself included you
know I'm just gonna go tomorrow
I started learning to ride the one-wheel
earlier this year I got really into it
and I started to show up earlier the
studio just so I can use the pint that
we have there and I found it really
helped me clear my mind
now anxiety is an issue that I'm sure a
lot of you face rend even talked about
it in his TED talk video for me it
manifests mostly as physical symptoms
like heightened heart rate or a sense of
impending doom and occasionally even
panic attacks the one-wheel like making
videos gave me an escape from anxious
thoughts and then I fell off and I got a
black eye and five stitches in my chin
and until now I've kind of stayed away
from it this is probably the most empty
I've ever seen the highways in LA it's
the last Thursday the mayor of Los
Angeles ordered that everybody remain in
their homes unless they have to perform
essential activities but he also left a
little exception for going outside so
we're using that as a green light to go
on a hike
a lot of people like myself have been
dealing with anxiety before all this
happened
and so now these anxious behaviors that
you have like social distancing or
compulsively cleaning that kind of gets
reinforced really heavily something I
realized while I was sitting in her
chair I felt more calm than I had felt
in a very long time
and I think the reason for that was the
one-wheel is pretty dangerous as I
discovered and because of that you have
to be absolutely aware while you're
riding it you have to be totally aware
of your surroundings it forces you to be
very present in the moment and of course
anxiety is a fear about the future and
it just made me realize that that's a
problem I have it's being present in the
moment and I'm sure anybody out there
who's dealing with anxiety you dwell a
lot on the way you're feeling on things
you're scared about and now is the time
that you would be sort of warranted in
dwelling on the future there's a lot of
unknowns out there it is kind of a scary
time and because of that it's vitally
important that we start or continue to
do things like cooking drawing
meditating getting outside and doing
things like hiking it really helps to
Center you and it kind of alleviates
that anxiety especially because that's
one of the few things that you can be
confident knowing like you're not going
to be spreading germs to other people or
you're not going to get them yourself a
little bit of anxiety is necessary to
keep us alert and secure so wash your
hands and stay home for a time but maybe
we can also try to live in the present
moment
so I hope you guys are staying safe out
there and I encourage you to leave a
comment down below if you have any
experience if you want to share with
anxiety
I know I've found that it can be very
cathartic to share these experiences and
hear about these experiences from other
people all right I'm gonna get back to
editing in these videos hey guys back at
Casa Watson here and I wanted to respond
to some of the comments from the last
video about people thought that I was
going crazy maybe a little bit that they
thought only two days into quarantine
and I was already losing my mind and I
gotta say it kind of was I hadn't done a
brand integration in about three videos
but thanks to Mac well then today's
sponsor all that's over now
who is Mac well they're a brand that's
gonna make you look and feel better and
they're gonna make a product that's
better than anything you're wearing
right now the first thing that they care
about is you the customer that's right
they're a premium men's essentials brand
that believes in smart products and
premium fabrics that's right thanks for
that and also well they do offer
underwear they also offer a whole slate
of other products awesome pants awesome
shirts awesome jackets they look good
and they're comfy Mac Weldon cares about
customer loyalty and they want you to be
comfortable so if you buy a pair of
underwear and you don't like it they're
gonna let you keep it and give you a
full refund no questions asked now
because Mac Weldon cares about its
customers and about loyalty they went
ahead and created the Weldon Blu program
it's super easy to sign up
[Music]
the first thing you got to do to sign up
for weld and blue is create an account
it's absolutely free and once you sign
up you'll never pay shipping again
second thing once you buy more than $200
through the weld and blue program you
immediately get 20% off all future
orders it's that simple
and the third thing that the weld and
blue program does new products before
anybody else isn't that amazing
that's right so if you guys want 20% off
your first order go over to Mack welding
calm and use the promo code corridor
crew and that's exactly what you'll get
isn't that great 20% off that's like $80
for a hundred dollar items all right so
that's it Mack welding comm use promo
code corridor crew 20% off that's it ok
bye see you later
bye yo so we made a playlist of all of
our favorite hobbies so if you are bored
during the quarantine and you want you
to learn how to make a really good
burrito for Jake I'll learn about how
Nick cleans ancient Roman coins check
out this playlist
I even have me painting a 3d printed
Catan set it's really cool
[Music]